we're joined from West London by the
fellow Chancellor John McDonald very
good morning to you I mean ultimately
what does labor think of the propagation
pretty angry angry I think we're
reflecting well I don't think it's just
labor I think we're reflecting the views
of the opposition parties in Parliament
certainly I think we're reflecting the
views of a large number of conservatives
as well and that includes people like
John Major a former conservative prime
minister is actually going to court to
try and prevent the prorogation I think
people feel that you know we live in a
parliamentary democracy and people have
given their lives to secure that Parma
to the boxing certain basic rights and
one of them is to ensure that Parliament
and the people are sovereign and just
because a Prime Minister is worried that
they'll lose a vote in parliament to
then use the tactic of closing down
Parliament in our poetry democracy is
unacceptable and yet propagation is you
know a part of setting up a new
Parliament a part of making sure that a
Queen's Speech can be delivered I mean
in may your shadow leader of the Commons
Valerie Bowers and made it very clear
that she and the party were very unhappy
that you hadn't had a Queen's speech and
it's very confused there was no specific
date for a new session I do not know of
any other government being run like this
she said you've got your Queen speech
now it's all in place why aren't you
happy with no nobody look nobody
believes that this is the normal process
of Parliament and the progression it of
course what you normally have is porra
Gatien you have a week off on maybe 10
days something like that then you have
the Queen's speech and that would be the
normal running a pomp this isn't about
the normal running a pub and to be
honest conservative MPs who come on the
media and Boris Johnson in particular I
think are insulting the intelligence of
the British people if they think we're
going to fall for that and you said
yourself you know Ben Wallace they can
serve to administer let the cat out of
the bag this is because they haven't got
a majority in palm
for this particular vote so like a
dictator what Boris Johnson's do so I'm
going to close down Parliament because
Parliament might vote against me we
can't accept that just imagine if Jeremy
Corbyn had done that the outrage that
there would have been on conservative
benches right the way across well there
is outrage on conservative benches even
because it's Boris Johnson more
importantly I think there are very many
people in the country who were angry
that you know you cannot allow a prime
minister to act in this way just because
they're going to lose a vote they closed
down Parliament what happens if not just
on this issue other issues come up is it
going to be normal practice from here on
the into that prime minister of any
political party to close down Parliament
in that way if we allow I think we're on
a slippery slope if we allow it to
happen this time
well you're not out of parliamentary
time yet you've got this coming week
which is no doubt gonna be a pretty busy
one what are you trying to get through
right okay we have got a week but don't
underestimate how difficult it is to
legislate within a week and the Prime
Minister knows that and that's why he's
pierogi in Parliament to try and prevent
us doing it
the cross-party group that has been
meeting that includes Conservative MPs
as well group of legal experts
constitutional experts MPs with decades
of experience are now looking to see how
on Tuesday and Wednesday and Thursday of
next week we can introduce a legislative
measure which will neighbors to prevent
a no deal without parliamentary approval
now the technique of that will be
published on the Tuesday and I'm hoping
I'm hoping that we'll have a debate in
which we can bring the house together
because I think there are a large number
of people in all political parties in
the House of Commons now who are
actually saying to Boris Johnson look
this is a wrong move think again and I
think some karma and wiser heads exactly
like David Gorkhas said now I think are
coming into play and I'm hoping at the
meeting that the Conservative MPs have
with Boris Johnson tomorrow are able to
pull up persuade him to pull back from
this measure but David Gore couldn't can
that he is pushing to get article 50
extended is is that an actual aim of the
Labour Party
well like David I'm not going into the
details of what will be brought forward
because the people are working together
on a cross-party basis yes some elements
in in confidence to maintain as well
maintain support but maintain respect
for their different views and what I
think we'll see is a group of people
putting party political politics to one
side to look after the interests of the
country but also not just about brexit I
think I think actually this is gone
beyond the brexit issue as well this is
about parliamentary sovereignty as well
so I think you'll see people coming
together I think taking a wise decision
on how best therefore to secure a route
through this and I'm hoping I'm hoping
at this late stage you know I'm hoping
that Boris Johnson and maybe you know
Dominic Cummings his key adviser who
seems to be running number 10 and the
treasurer at the moment I'm hoping that
they'll listen and pull back people that
are going to want to know of what your
ultimate goal is here because if you're
trying to get if you ultimate goal
Stephen give me a second if you're
trying to get a bigger deal if you're
trying to get a good deal a good you
know renegotiated withdrawal agreement
which the EU says is it's not gonna do
there is a very real argument to be made
isn't there that says if you actually
strip away the power of the Prime
Minister to leave with no deal what you
actually do is take away his negotiating
hands and you're not going to get a
decent deal no the other at goal very
straightforwardly this week is to ensure
that Parliament can have a final say
that's the first thing we cannot have a
Prime Minister overriding Parliament not
just on this issue on any issue so the
ultimate goal this week is secure
parliamentary sovereignty that's the
first thing the second thing is of
course as far as I'm concerned that the
goal is to prevent a no deal because I
think a no deal would be incredibly
damaging there's no mandate for no deal
so of course but the most important
thing this week
is to make sure that Parliament can have
a say on that we can't have a situation
where Parliament has no say purely
because her Prime Minister thinks they
can lose a vote if you don't get the
numbers this coming week which of course
is a possibility then there's been all
the talk of the idea of vote of
confidence in the government is that
still on the table as far as Labour is
concerned no yes yes it is it has to be
it has to be we've got our view is we've
got to use every mechanism we possibly
can to prevent a no deal and that
clearly is still on the table the
problem that we've got is exactly is
other constitutional experts have said
but actually the problem is time and
that's why the Prime Minister's used
this measure it's very difficult to get
legislation through in a matter of a few
days and that the Prime Minister knows
that and that's why they're using this
tactic I think there's a very grubby I
think it's a grubby measure and I've as
I say it's unprecedented and we we can't
allow Prime Minister acted in this way
just think if there's another issue cut
that comes up but any Prime Minister
could be defeated on and they just sort
of well blow that I'll close down
Parliament but compromise everything
everything about our constitutional
status that we now have but people are
questioning whether actually the the
no-confidence option is a real one for
the Labour Party Jacob Riis MOG has been
writing in the mail on Sunday today
saying you you're not prepared to do it
really because it could well force a
general election and the mail on Sunday
Delta poll out today has you 11 points
behind the Conservatives you don't want
a general election I really do you know
I let me just say message to Boris
Johnson value general election bring it
on at the last general election we were
24 points behind and we virtually drew
level with the Conservatives if he wants
to bring up Tony election I'd bring it
about but what we're saying this week
actually the more important thing is not
about party advantage or anything like
that
it is actually making sure we secure the
basis of our democracy
parliamentary sovereignty but also it's
a matter of ensuring that for us or many
of us is about blocking no deal because
no deal under under the government's own
assessments could be catastrophic for
our economy for people's jobs and for
people's living standards so possibly
gonna oppose a measure like that if
you're so opposed to a No Deal and the
EU was saying we're not actually gonna
renegotiate the withdrawal agreement do
you wish you'd voted for it now no I
went into negotiations for six weeks
with members of the cabinet the Tory
cabinet to try and see if we could agree
a deal and there was virtually no
movement whatsoever we couldn't agree a
deal that would protect jobs in the
economy so there was no way that we
could sign up for and then also when we
went through those negotiations we were
negotiating with conservatives who
accepted that the end of the day they
couldn't deliver on a deal either and
they were falling apart in fact they
were arguing in front of us so that was
not feasible what we did our best but we
couldn't secure a deal that we felt
could protect jobs in the economy and on
that basis we couldn't sign up to
anything
um on Wednesday we know obviously part
of it part of the whole plan this week
is to take control of parliamentary
business to control the order papers if
that happens will we still get the
spending review would that still happen
well they'll be determined by the
government they will determine the
agenda beyond the issue around whether
or not we can sort out a parliamentary
process to deal with brexit if the
government do bring its spending review
forward obviously we will analyze it but
what I'm concerned about is that
spending review is actually a spending
round it's a one-year spending review
from it's not the normal process so it
looks to me actually it looks to me like
a pre-election stunt a gimmick a gimmick
budget if you like where they'll promise
spend a bit of money here and there
based upon what they're reading on the
opinion polls but already what we're
is that a lot of the money that they're
promised I saw three announcements of
existing money goes nowhere near enough
to tackle the well the the backlog of
austerity over the last nine years under
under the Tories and there's pretty
disillusioning for many of those
professionals on the front line who
really do need long-term stable
investment in their public services and
yet I mean if the government loses
control of Parliament this week you you
stand a real chance don't you of being
accused and the spending of you doesn't
happen you could be you could stand
accused of of actually stopping 400
million pounds extra for schools two
billion for hospitals and additional
20,000 police officers not at all three
years people not turn around and say oh
you've stopped that happening no not at
all what will make sure we do this week
I hope is prevent a No Deal make sure we
have restoration of parliamentary
sovereignty but also would be quite
happy to accommodate the government if
it wants an extra few days for the
spending rule review I'd be quite happy
to accommodate them but actually I'd
like a real spending review one that
really does end austerity that really
does put investment back into our public
services not a well what is an
electioneering stunt by the looks of it
from what's coming from the government
at the moment John McDonnell good to
talk to you thank you thanks